[Music]
what if the Sun disappeared right now
would you be able to handle eternal
darkness cold temperatures how about
flying off into space the Sun is the
only star in our solar system and it
gives life to everything here on earth
would we even be alive if it vanished
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Sun disappeared the truth
is we wouldn't even notice for the first
eight and a half minutes this is how
long it takes sunlight to travel to our
planet so even if the Sun disappeared
its last ray of light would take 510
seconds to reach your skin and what
about gravity the Sun is the dominant
gravitational force in our solar system
it has all eight planets moving around
it so if the Sun disappeared would we
fly off into space yes but not right
away the force of gravity turns out to
have speed - it is theory of general
relativity Einstein proved that gravity
is just as fast as light and not
instantaneous as was previously thought
this means the earth would still be
orbiting a recently vanished star with
no clue of the upcoming darkness but
just for eight and a half minutes when
the last of the sun's rays reach the
earth eternal night wouldn't be our only
problem the very same moment the Sun
disappeared from the sky earth would
start traveling into space at 18 miles
per second assuming the earth didn't
collide with any other planets or
asteroids or get sucked into a black
hole it would be moving in a straight
line for 43,000 years before it found
another star to orbit but you wouldn't
have to worry about that within two
seconds the moon would go dark since
there would be no sunlight to reflect
but the stars would still shine and your
electricity would still work unless it's
powered by solar panels however gravity
and illumination aren't the only things
we rely on the Sun for plants need the
Sun for photosynthesis turning light
into energy is how plants stay alive
without sunlight most small plants would
be dead within days larger ones like
trees would survive for several decades
due to their slow metabolism this would
knock out the bottom tier of the food
chain most animals would die off slowly
only scavengers
the dead would remain until they froze
to death because within a week the
average temperature on earth would drop
to a bone-chilling 32 degrees Fahrenheit
and by the end of the first year minus
150 degrees would be the new norm and it
would keep dropping until stabilizing at
minus 400 degrees Fahrenheit
the oceans would grow colder too but
just on the surface
thanks to geothermal vents they would
remain liquid underneath
despite being buried under a thick layer
of ice so if you're lucky enough to
survive consider moving to the ocean
floor in the end the organisms living
around those geothermal vents would be
the only living beings not to notice any
difference they don't need the Sun to
live and could continue to thrive for
billions of years until the planet
became a frozen chunk of rock drifting
in space
[Music]